non-minimalists
i just sold a house that had two
dumpsters
worth of things and more of my
belongings in it
why didn't it make me feel good to
unload it all
brenda let me tell you why there's a
specific reason why it didn't feel good
because you wanted it to feel good
you're running if you're
if you want to feel good
that is actually the problem thinking
that letting go is going to feel good
what did i say when we started
the minimal episode earlier this week
right it was letting go isn't always
fun yeah but it is always freeing
freedom doesn't always feel good in fact
sometimes freedom is painful
yeah it's like saying i went to the gym
and worked out really hard why don't i
feel good right now yeah well because of
the
the literal growing pains here you're
going to experience pain if your
expectation
is for you to feel good
then what are you doing you're running
from misery
instead of running from misery what
we're running toward
is freedom freedom from stuff freedom
from
the mind freedom from the chaos
ultimately
what we have in our homes and in our
sentimental items
is noise and the narrative we've created
for ourselves
is i need that noise in order to
function
it's going to make me happy and then
when it doesn't make us happy the new
narrative we create
is oh i'm going to be happy
if i get rid of the things that aren't
making me happy
no no that's also a chase that's a
pursuit
happiness or contentment or tranquility
are only
uncovered and those things come from a
particular kind
of freedom the freedom that we get from
letting go
is often painful at first is often
uncomfortable but that discomfort is the
place from which
we grow the most yeah
you have to let go without any
expectations it makes me think about
the movie inception and how everyone was
talking about how awesome this movie was
and you have to go see it in the theater
and it's amazing and you're gonna love
it and it's twists and turns and blah
blah blah blah so like i hyped it up
went and watched it and it was such a
huge letdown
and i often think like maybe it wouldn't
have been a letdown if i didn't have
that crazy expectation of like this is
gonna be one of the best movies i've
seen in a long time
yeah uh if i just because often i will
go into a movie actually having a low
expectation like oh this isn't gonna be
that good
and then i watch it and i'm like
actually i enjoyed that
right that was good so there's something
to be said about the expectations um
our expectations in life in general but
specifically specifically with your
stuff
yes you have to unload it without
expectations yes because nothing is
going to
nothing that you can get rid of is going
to bring you elation right
i mean you know you i can't think of any
example
you might feel a weight lifted yeah let
go of this stuff but don't
mistake that for happiness or
contentment or joy
that is simply setting something down by
the way you picked up the weight
and you've been carrying it for a while
so you're exhausted by that weight
but setting down the weight doesn't make
you happy
it just relieves some of the burden
gives you some of the freedom but now
when you have that newfound freedom
i talked earlier about my friend who
went to prison for a long time
and then he came out of prison not
knowing
what to do and he thought that getting
out of prison would make him
feel good or happy but it not
necessarily what it did is it gave him
the freedom what he chooses to do with
that freedom
is up to him yeah there's something too
about you know maybe brenda just got rid
of stuff thinking
well i'm gonna be a minimalist i'm gonna
throw all my stuff out
but if you didn't ask that question
before you threw your stuff out how
might my life be better with less if you
didn't get to the why
then it's a to anyone out there it's
it's a possibility
that you just start throwing out stuff
and you're going to be like brenda and
be like why am i not happy
and it could be as simple as you didn't
stop to ask that question
how might my life be better with less
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today